what I love most about events like these
it's not just the spreading of ideas but
it's that people come together and I
think we often forget that humanity is
made up of humans it's made up of
individuals and one of the things that
made the human race so successful is not
that the word they're strongest or that
were the smartest it's that there were
social animals we have the ability to
form communities cultures
what's a community what's a culture it's
a group of people with a common set of
values and beliefs
what's a company it's a group of people
with a common set of values and beliefs
what's a nation it's a group of people
with a common set of values and beliefs
one was surrounded by people who believe
what we believe something remarkable
happens Trust emerges
make no mistake of it Trust is a feeling
trust is a distinctly human experience
it's not a checklist simply doing
everything that's expected of you
doesn't mean people will trust you it
just means that you're responsible
Trust is a feeling it is a very powerful
feeling and it only comes from being
surrounded by people who believe what
you believe I'll share with you an
example that freaks me out every time I
talk about it
what's our most valued possession on the
planet it's our children right our
children our most valuable possession on
the planet so let's game out of scenario
let's say you want to go on a date so
you need a babysitter you have two
choices
option number one there's a 16 year old
from just down the street with barely if
any babysitting experience option number
two there's a 32 year old who just moved
into the neighborhood you don't know
from where but she's got ten years of
babysitting experience who do you choose
you choose the 16 year old think about
that you would rather trust your most
valued possession on the planet with
somebody with no experience but they're
from within your community over somebody
with vast amounts of experience and yet
you don't know where they come from or
where they belong or if you can trust
them or why should they trust you then
why do we do it differently at work why
are we more obsessed with someone's
resume in what they've done and how much
money they've earned for our company
can they help us and yet we never think
to ask or understand do you belong here
how can we trust you how can you trust
us one of the greatest challenges any
organization has believe it or not is
its own success all organizations start
out the same way there's some sort of
metric usually money in this case and
time and when an organization is founded
what they do and why they do it are in
extra inextricably linked and that's
because there's usually a founder or
some small group of founders with some
vision of the world that doesn't exist
Zipp exist yet and they're filled with
passion and they attract people who
believe what they believe and those
people join up and they want to work
with them but then they get more
successful and they're no longer relying
on their gut decision on each other now
they have to start hiring people who
hire someone who hire somebody who hire
somebody who has to make a decision
based on what and that original cause
gets forgotten although they do really
really well here the original reason why
they started the company gets forgotten
and all of a sudden weird things start
to happen I call this the split and when
an organization goes through the split
there are a few symptoms the old-timers
will say it's not like it used to be
it's not like it used to be and yet they
can't put it into words what do you mean
it's not like it used me just doesn't
feel the same they say are there
symptoms of the split or when stress
goes up and passion goes down you work
really hard at the beginning how did how
come it didn't feel stressful then and
very often you become more obsessed with
what your competition is doing over what
you are doing in organizations as they
become really successful this starts to
go away and what you start to see is
that even though they're making more
money and even though they're selling
more fulfillment does not go up in fact
what does go up is distrust we stop
trusting management we stop trusting
each other even now my fear my thought
is that maybe America has gone through a
split if you go back to the greatest
generation our grandparents we call them
the greatest generation think about that
for a second why did they get the label
the greatest generation I'm Gen X that's
unfair
I got a variable the unknown variable at
that they get the greatest generation I
get X okay why were they the greatest
generation because they were a part of
something they were all united in
pursuit of something bigger than
themselves there are stories of young
men who shot themselves when they didn't
get called to action the population
bought war bonds we were all together we
trusted each other we trusted our
leaders and off we went to be a part of
something bigger than ourselves but then
the war ended and then they came back
and I felt like they'd missed out on
life being at war and they grew up in
the depression and so they set all of
that intense loyalty and that's intense
trust and they went to work and we know
what to find the 1950s this is when you
gave your life to your company you work
for years until you gave up and got your
gold watch right absolute loyalty and
what we started to see was a growth in
wealth in the country growth in GDP and
an increase in affluence but that same
sense of fulfillment wasn't there
because now they were working hard but
they weren't feeling a part of something
anymore and the distrust started to show
up and in response was the hippie
movement and the hippie movement could
happen because there was more social
welfare the country could afford it for
people to fall off the grid and a lot of
those kids who were joining the hippie
movement they had rich parents and so
they could afford to go away and run up
and you know pretend to do something but
that sense of fulfillment that seeking
seeking you know to rebellion against
their parents affluence it didn't have
that same sense of fulfillment they
weren't getting it in a hippie community
and then you had the 1970s the Me
Generation and everybody thought that
you know you had to find some spiritual
guru before you could find some sense of
fulfillment and cults or all those
sudden were on the rise and that evolved
into the 1980s still very very me
focused Gordon Gekko greed is good
except this time it went from
spirituality into business all of a
sudden business was good it wasn't dirty
to be a part of a business anymore and
for the first time in history in the
1980s theories were proposed to use
people to balance the books this was the
first time we started to see massive
layoffs of human beings in order to make
the numbers work then you had the 1990s
a period still self-involved
come boom and that didn't so work so
well and now we're in the latest period
in this new decade of uncertainty and
searching we know that this hippie
movement thing didn't work in the
obsession with that money thing didn't
work but as our country continued to the
GDP started to go up and fluid started
to go up this started to go away and
that sense of purpose and that sense of
cause went away now technology hasn't
helped even Andy Grove the founder of
Intel said the only thing the
microprocessor really ever does is make
things go faster
and that's exactly what technology has
done it's made that go faster right
technology is wonderful for making
connections technology is wonderful for
the exchange of information technology
is amazing for driving transactions you
can perform transactions faster and
faster than we've ever performed them
but technology is terrible for creating
human relationships there was a time
when a desktop meant something
horizontal today it means something
vertical and there was a an a folder is
a picture of a thing we used to use now
that's a fun example but technology has
co-opted some very human things as well
a friend is not somebody who checked
their status your network doesn't happen
on LinkedIn a dialog doesn't happen on
Twitter and a conversation doesn't
happen on a blog
these are human experiences and they
could require human beings to be in the
room even bloggers
I love how bloggers talk about the
Internet as the end-all be-all of the
world and that every year they come
together 20,000 of them descend on Las
Vegas to have a conference why couldn't
they do it online it's because you've
got to have the human Union in the 1960s
a man by the name of Stanley Milgram did
an experiment he wanted to understand
how the Holocaust could happen and so he
wanted understand how an entire
population could stand by and watch a
genocide happen or some could even
contribute and the excuse they gave was
I'm just following orders and so he did
this what we know now is a terribly
unethical experiment but amazing results
he had a volunteer come in and that
volunteer was told that they would play
the role of a teacher and there was
another volunteer who was really a
scientist pretending to be a volunteer
who would play the role of the student
that teacher was sat at a table that had
a button and a dial
and the teacher was told that the
student would be asked a series of
questions and if the question was wrong
or if they refused to answer they would
have pushed the button and administer an
electric shock now in reality there was
only one electric shock given the whole
experiment it was a very small one given
to the teacher so they could know what
it felt like and the dial they were told
after each question they were to turn
the dial up one notch and it said sort
of mild medium you know somewhat painful
extremely painful very painful and it
went red and then it said xxx
and as they would start the experiment
they would start giving the electric
shock the other scientist would pretend
that they were in pain and they pretend
that they were getting an electric shock
and the person would feel bad and they
look to the scientist and say I'm
hurting the guy and the authority figure
would look down and say I'm afraid the
experiment must go on
the experiment really must go on and
some of them would mutter to themselves
the experiment must go on the experiment
was gone as I continued to press the
button what the what the results
revealed is that when the teacher could
see and hear the student they couldn't
go very far before they completely quit
the experiment when they could hear them
but not see them they could go further
but still not very far before they quit
when they could see them but not here
then they could go further but still not
very far but when they could neither see
nor hear the impact of their decisions
65% of those teachers were able to go
all the way and kill the guy and you
know what they were concerned with I'm
not gonna be responsible am i the reason
it's an unethical experiment is because
sixty-five percent of people who thought
they were good people when they walked
in the door went home with the knowledge
that they could kill another human being
now think about how we do business today
there was a time that if you wanted to
know what your employees thought about
you you walked on the factory floor and
you asked them there was a time when
Custis customer service meant you talk
to a human being
now customer services you'll get a reply
to your email in 24 hours
I saw a bank advertising that you get to
talk to a human being
I earned miles up the wazoo in one of
the airline's you know one of the things
they gave me for my status a phone
number to talk to a person since when is
a person a luxury our survival depend
on it now think about how we do business
we do business on screens companies
manage their businesses on screens and
the more they make the more disconnected
they come from the founding of the
company the less they talk to their own
people they less they see and hear the
impact of their own decisions it's not a
surprise that we're putting poison in
foods chemicals and foods and now
scientists are saying that if we
continue down this path this generation
will have a shorter lifespan and
previous generation that's not
surprising to me when you cannot see nor
hear the impact of the decisions you
make 65 percent of us have the ability
to kill someone what we need is more
human interactions what we need is to
shake hands we need we need a handshake
leadership we need handshake
conversations we need handshake friends
we need handshake dialogues we need
handshake meetings imagine if you were
to meet somebody you do a deal with them
you get along great they say I agree to
all the terms and I'm totally gonna do
business with you and you go great shake
on it and they go I don't need to shake
your hand oh come on we agree let's
shake on it
why don't you shake your hand I agree to
all your terms you won't do business
with them because they won't shake your
hand that's how powerful human
interaction is what we need to do is set
out and shake hands more often put
ourselves in situations where we can
create real human connections and where
trust becomes the standard and not the
exception thank you very much
[Applause]